The
next excerpt is taken from original tape W ninety
seven
when you when you
mourn his loss sometimes they give
you no award for that nappy and sinner
in the best grades or
some like them. That is always a little like you
are just a piece of paper saying that. You know the dice craze of
the school year. Mrs
Dunn says Danny
Birch because he didn't do nothing to see as another teacher come
in every
day teaching for
our
school to clap whether
you seem
to know or
just well quarter to just esteem to a quarter
to
Sandra grew Cynthia
Cynthia Cynthia trial.
Joanne Lord in the fakery.
Barbara. Janet corpus a bit to care
less about ten and a pony.
No ma'am and I can
hear about three or
four move next block across there and the other one says downtown are by my
count never near Don't
stop.
I
mean this is Catholic school we can fix cars.
And there's niggers in school but I don't have any my
class. Because of the other language.
I
know
you're
an occultist.
She said she's
been sure is
not yours appears to share dresses
and go go boots in gym class.
And
somebody new moved here. Because
they were kind of friends there.
I mean because there are age maybe I don't think I play some
because I would know she'd be a legal question but she probably makes sense and I go from the
store. She probably would be probably the public
school. There were if there was one of
your when you
read.
It said to be nice for Mike to do so you have to be able to go and the kids
have to be able to go
places where
the
teacher kid again to where they're like.
Five years.
Yeah.
Well a teacher or A B C and how to count. And see the signs
and they play games
and. They read them stories and they have
the
absentee and sometimes the teacher or teacher in some manner.
You know I should put some little math problems in the the government book in a handwriting book.
Little things how to spell
and
you know.
I take her place I go for
ninth or. A lot.
Here. What can
you do.
Instead of paid my bike to color it is no I painted
pink bluish white and blue.
My girlfriend. If her brush into the wrong color paint made on
mocking you from
the stuff I got for my birthday
last year I got this game that
had a dollar in it. No not again. Yes again the head out of my
girlfriend but nobody knew how to play it and my girlfriend extern took it over to her house one day to
play with it because I was sick and they wrecked it and they had
to leave a little car that.
They reacted so my like to live that always so I would give it to and I could
keep something but a spy.
You know.
Except for your arm around. The dramatist.
They're safe and not know of a genie and
he she say she has a
way. Yeah.
You know there's no way. Somebody was different than we do with
something that everybody.
Well she walks around funny. So she's did show up put our
mouth open wide. And she's
dead and she bought a pit she says a million but appears so glasses
never I want to use them she's They know it's big fat Christine can't use them but when we
go to those women you know my name her sure. Jeannie and
Ron bought the pool.
And so my mom said everybody shares it because they are not his but that water.
So those guys. Whenever I go to get in my grill be genie Nori.
And my cousin Tommy they'll say BIG said Christine. Not
all water
out is only.
You know. You know when
you are pretty.
If you had been there
was money was always there much you want to buy
brand new
race to Barbie
dishes. I have a
look playhouse in the back yard with real furniture and dish.
Chairs and real for me rugs that you didn't wish to them and
bouncing real back including keep it clean a day or so I like to clean house.
I had clued at you. Yeah about ten
feet
high. And they
wouldn't like it if I were rife with their. You
know you know. Last year
on every case should I make my
mother the fireman.
She was and he worked them
pierced and. If
there's no fires or anything just place cars and watch T.V.'s leaked.
Except for his house
where you know at the
site they have to do the best thing they have to the cookie.
And they have to do the sweeping the floors and shining the fire engine
so they all get rusty and six in their boots and stuff so they're not all
sloppy and they have the wax the floors and fix up or as I
said and different things like that I work with
and they just drop everything and run to the fire
dept and. Sure
no one can
own uptown. Takoma Park. Teacher.
On any street.
I know halfassed McNicholas and. I don't know the
value of the town part towards trade
really you
know what would have will say
John are. You know that
out of twelve.
Third and second.
Eight mile seven mile. Sequinned or.
State Fair. They know Davis. But.
Woodward.
You
know where shit you live
or liberal
I know.
And like highways. I would use
an
expressway.
To try you
know. I lived on brush West or I was born and then we moved to resist.
Kamloops lived in house so we moved over Carolyn
again and then we were told my grandmother's house that we moved over
here.
And
we. Have
you trust me
you
know when
you're here for here we
go we're going to leave you Saturday.
Well as we flew like
here and my dad
brought up thirteen dollars or the choice to play along with their balls and
their girl said look plastic was. Is a choice and
we bought a pair of shoes to win the lottery
because it's one that almost everything you can think
of you're going to go for one week with this week's issue.
We were. We're going to sell the place but there we can get it there. He still for two weeks. So the moment
it started the next person goes for two
weeks. You know.
What Hardy
That's right Easter Christmas and stuff because
my grandmother saying
to excuse
me we here we have my cousins are all
they way plans that's because look my cousins are boys and we plant the backyard and
running games and an easterly play Heidi exactly and we find
them Christmas she buys us a little gift you know better care of yourself
that we like and we have sausages
because we're polish and.
Baked beans and everything but I almost feel
big games up
Graham and.
I don't know what you what it's called.
It's
brown. Like a hotdog. But it isn't that's only.
Yeah. You know my grandpa doesn't cook
a turkey and ham and
chicken bread and rolls.
Was
actually research. She
doesn't took VERY MUCH MUCH time my grandfather cooks and we never say
you
know what that we just.
Depends what day my dad works
just as.
I don't know a scene where we have the. Reasons that he'll call for after it's all
cooked or
disappear. What you are sensing
is
this. Pick up this high
and has been closed and almost
every day of
paper.
Life
because
we had a party for many years to look I'm stuck and I
get thirty three dollars whistle for money my grandmother gave me a radio
and I get parts of my book with ten dollars and my grandmother gave
me that radio that cost fifteen dollars points five more down.
Yes and. I got a mess we're going to break but no we just had
a little bit a cake.
Heart shaped necklace and it opened a new pitcher
said I could get it.
And. Probably. Oh sometimes we'll
get just up and go out
and
help the poor can use the bodies like the way appear in the pit.
One of
the
old pumpkins.
Most the time she takes it cuts her face out. It takes eat up from in
the oven when they come conceit and then we eat.
With the pumpkin she puts a candle
in Splash. You know those things inside a pumpkin where
you take away your wash and good.
When you put him a plate so they're all spread out. And then put them in the oven and result
of when inside when you open them they get that little piece of meat or whatever it is.
Can you make.
That really ever.
Year which
you know where your
way. Of the desk. He appeared
tights
slippers purple rub sticks. I think it was black
eye
shadow. And I had a bunch
of our own
just here.
And then Abby It'll put a bit of a certain that I really
think.
My mom.
We're going to show just.
You know. I'm the one I wanted the I think I'll
be clean something. Real
silky gowns and I
mean look at me.
And some so please a nice and clean.
Most of one of
our
sensory
trigger tree.
Say trigger tree or something so hit me on
the back and tell me not to say it. And then we say to get.
Help the
poor give me some money
your
way.
To cheat when I go take
health checks help the poor and give me some money to
buy a new pair appear because they don't think it's right.
OK I just you know.
Kick you.
Oh no I am always in the fight.
You
can't commit to any base for me as I just said
Shelly pushes and kick and it's cheered hero square chin and
pulling same
way like me a mile up so they always row when I go they have to
flame
you just know.
You
know about. Somebody
was fighting for you know here by me
and all of a sudden
somebody you know for
has put a sticker.
First I kick Um I punch in the stomach. I get real close
up into him and he put my name on it as a shove I give him a
little and they're going write that poem if they
suppose.
When you want to do this from day one against a whole bunch.
You'll see it's two against me to him or some posters do you
handle most or type. Well sometimes.
You know Malaysia's can't fight. This is one boy down black he's real scaredy cat anybody
can beat him
up there was Jerry.
Journey right. And one time he said he could beat me up before he knew I could
be him up. We started fighting and he's got a bloody
nose and I didn't do it you know he said I did get real man started
hitting and a couple of his boyfriends only so I guess kick them and they
ran. You know.
Yeah. She grew during virus.
You know our drinks nail polish. Polish remover like
pap and Genie drink bottle
of nail polish
to get to the MacBook though.
I don't know.
I don't know I don't like to stay
home no A Do I gotta do
work like the Fed also with the way little commercial take or does there. Take a live.
I guess.
We're on a picnic and well. Mrs tickle best image she's my mom didn't know if there was a bet
and so she said Tater so I took it and when we came back there was a word is
a she isn't trash throw away and my mom said go still the
way Chris I was the largest the lowest I said I've already did some work she will do some more
work. So away we go here.
Use them over at my group for joy
it's. Yeah.
Jim and me
long ago latches old
really. No way just tired the
road.
Yeah has a has a but my uncle was over babysitting that day and he was
about
fifteen. He took the Sears chest
downstairs put it up so it's like an army take their plane early.
My mom came home and I had the House and the live pool players know everything all over
the place.
I know you don't
come for me
I catch a cold.
And yeah my mom was going to
agree like you spoke to the ladies that see the lights and she said
My mom should wait for it she didn't see the light the first lady
says young lady won't you watch re going you see me coming why say just that for you my
last lesson ladies is a lie up
there mate as I don't see
it.
Not because she just says well there's a light up there.
And I'm not going to do anything but you have to pay for those bloody You know she hit it on the
door like you know my uncle just want
to get Carrie Simmons that
happened to go anywhere with my mom or
anything
and yell for them to get all banged
up
any situation with.
Your permission. We are place
and
right now. Yeah.
So one time when I was a dream. I had a dream that I was locked in the
freezer and I was freezing to death but then I. Through the. Three a core
part for study the call cuts my
list right.
Because what you say to
these people say that
some didn't you
say just
like
I said God
loves you but
you must think that
be pretty Christian
is going to help you up
an in even though they have
been discovered by you to which you probably just take it.
When you write. something